are you sure you don't need any help dr
reed i already said so didn't i
go on
take the night off
all right
see you tomorrow
clear
bring the team in
she's lost too much blood
we can't save her the body perhaps
but the mind could be salvaged
even if it were possible the trauma
would be unimaginable
shut up
just do it
there's no risk
no journey into the unknown
then there's no discovery
ash
i see
so you've been tucked away all this time
you're nothing but dust on my path
eight sex ninety-two
[Music]
they needed
[Music]
infecting me with your weakness
that's a lie
who is this
who are you
one one four nine five
now i see
the cause of every failure was here
it wasn't my fault i they were supposed
to do
seven eight
one one
i do what it takes
i always have you think that was you
pitiful
i will show you what true strength is
that's the full sequence
let's see if she's in there then
lillian
is that you darling dr sammers
mary
you survived you're not lillian no no no
you can't even be hard please you have
to stop her i
i know what happened to newton
what
i will rid myself of you but until then
thank you dr summers you've given me
some very valuable information
now
to put it to you
[Music]
you